Britain's a terrorist State America is a
terrorist State and Israel is a
terrorist
State terrorist State and salute to him
and that fat Egghead that fat flipping
Humpty Dumpty Egghead couldn't even get
him
out brothers and sisters just imagine
for a second that you give £10 in
donation and that £1 is used to buy food
or bricks or whatever to help the people
in Gaza but then just imagine this
amazing D that you want to do but we
turn it into a moneymaking machine how
the W is exactly that they take your
money and every single time the money
generated from that W that building is
going to go to our Palestinian brothers
and sisters for the next 20 30 40 50 60
100 150 years and this will be a form of
true click the link below and donate may
Allah subhana bless and preserve you
guys brothers and sisters and dear
friends Great Britain in the west the
Western World who Champions their
freedom of speech uh you know uh a
democratic country which we allow you to
say whatever you like whenever you like
however you like U as long as you are
insulting Islam and desecrating the
Quran and uh talking ill about the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him yes
but if you dare to criticize our allies
uh we are strategically consistent not
morally we want to thank Israel and all
of their Muppets yes and all these
bloody clowns who clearly show their
double standards and hypocrisy this
going to go down in history thank you
very much for showing you do not believe
in democracy you do not believe in
freedom of speech you do not believe in
Freedom of movement or freedom to to
wear we're going to watch a video on
that on talk TV look at this individual
Steve who is wearing the Palestinian
scarf the fact that he was wearing that
yes the fact that he was wearing that
what did he do he got in trouble so you
don't you don't have even freedom to
wear what you want to wear let's watch
it for ourself inallah and let's see how
this flipping baldheaded Egghead yeah he
looks like a flipping Egghead yeah he
looks like an absolute egg yeah this
Egghead how he tried to physically kick
this guy out his studio for what reason
let's watch for ourself plenty of money
for Wars they've got plenty of money to
give Ukraine they've got plenty of money
to give Israel they could sell an you
completely stupid Steve are you
completely nuts I mean you come in here
dressed in a in a scarf with a
Palestinian you actually support the
Palestinians absolutely
about ham what about H I defend the
Palestinians right they defend
themselves do you say Hamas it was a
resistance sorry I I believe the Israeli
government are a fascist government I
believe the Israeli government are a
terrorist democra it's a
Dem Democratic this is this is not on
you want to talk rubbish go and talk to
the BBC or some other you about H what
about what about Free Speech ham a relig
from Israel that's war of course it has
well not has defend
no because it's it's an occupied people
it be selfdefense they're not occupied
it was 20 I don't want you in here
anymore Steve because you are supporting
the enemies throwing me out James
because you defender of free speech are
throwing me out you've had Free Speech
but I don't Defender Free Speech or
throw me out I am war with the
Palestinian children who you're
murdering in their thousandal damage
it's
ille it's the lowest amount of Cal
damage ever they on
you Britain's a terrorist State America
is a terrorist State and Israel is a
terrorist State terrorist State James
you trying to me James you're trying to
assult me James I'm an old man with
cancer Jam don't please do what I I'm
not going to I'm not going to go and you
won't be able to remove me J so please
don't why you what are you going to do
well I'm making a St I'm making a
statement here for statement of of
rubbish book and go out and support
Palestine I know you want to hit me I'm
not going to hit you you're
[Music]
absolutely look at the attitude he is
clearly saying and I'll be honest with
you I'll stick by these flipping words
Israel is thousand times worse than
Hamas with the atrocities that they
committed with us religious people we
are strategically not consistent we are
morally consistent as Muslims our
religion tells us to condemn anybody for
killing innocent people like Allah says
in the Quran which is very interesting
that Allah is talking about bani is the
children of Israel yes back then talking
to them and we have told them not to
kill an innocent Soul it's interesting
zionists these zionists as you can see
have a track record from back then to
now of killing innocent people Allah
tells us in the Quran very clearly when
we confronted the farit we would tell
them nowh in our religion does it tell
us to go and kill innocent men women and
children the far right Tommy Robinson
the bastard scum dog and all of the far
right have gide
they are using actual scripture from
their Bible from the Old Testament to
they're quoting it and committing atres
by killing innocent people and babies
guess what guess what you see this
across the board with all the zionists
from your lay man to everybody like I've
say this I've been repeating this it's
crazy we as Muslims when Isis was
committing atrocities we never ever
supported them and condemn condemned
them when they were using our scriptures
yes how the tables have turned and shown
that you guys the far right and the
Christian Lobby who's supporting Israel
and the Zionist those scumback idea and
all of them from top to bottom are
calling for an outright Massacre and a
genocide which they are doing it
themselves while they quot the Bible of
amalekites and all he had to all this
guy done was what talk about it yes he
was all all of a sudden because of the
scarf that he's wearing he became Pro
Hamas he was Pro resistant yes the
Palestinians have a right to Arms
resistance that is the right that's been
given to them by the UN so brothers and
sisters you can see that do not believe
do not feel inferior to the Western man
especially this Egghead yeah don't feel
inferior because they are double
standard Hypocrites they are liars they
have no backbone and the same thing
happened when me and Muhammad hijab went
to the freedom of speech event and we
was stopped and we was jumped yes it
shows you that it is all a disguise this
is all a pretense a lie to tell you guys
we're pro freedom of speech why did I
not get the chance as a Muslim to speak
at that freedom of speech event because
they don't believe in freedom of speech
unless it is against Muslims they have
shown their double standards and
hypocrisy alhamdulillah may Allah guide
this guy who is doing the cause for the
Palestinians may Allah subhana T guide
him to Islam like he did with many
people and salute to him and that fat
Egghead that fat flipping Humpty Dumpty
Egghead couldn't even get him out and he
said what he had to say and he put him
in his place and it is right and we want
to thank Israel for showing the whole
world your true colors please carry on
the entire world has witnessed what kind
of savages you zionists are that you do
not care about men women children or
babies you do not brothers and sisters
bear that in
mind
brothers and sisters just imagine for a
second that you give £10 in donation and
that £1 is used to buy food or bricks or
whatever to help the people in Gaza but
then just imagine this amazing de that
you want to do but we turn it into a
money-making machine how the W is
exactly that they take your money and
every single time the money generated
from that W that building is going to go
to our Palestinian brothers and sisters
for the next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150
years and this will be a form of
true click the link below and donate may
Allah subhana bless and preserve you
guys